that he was surprised when we invited
him which which I found horribly
offensive but at the same time I found
that it really meant that it is the time
that we do these things more often and
invite people like Andrew I have to
thank our friends and colleagues at moma
especially undress lepak undress is the
curator of contemporary architecture and
he has just opened a show which all of
you should go see called small scale big
change at museum of modern art of which
andrew is one of the 11 groups that are
that are represented and I think you'll
tell us a little bit about the show will
you but but I want to plug it and now he
has no choice but I want to plug it and
say that that that everyone should go so
thank you so much for coming and please
give a warm welcome
Thank You Ben thanks for introducing I'm
happy to have the opportunity again here
to introduce another lecture with
related with the show in moma
small-scale big change and if you
haven't seen it then I really invited
you to come and see it and to see the
other the other 10 projects in the show
and I it's a extreme pleasure for me
like to have Andrew here and for the
lecture here in Colombia because like
last year when i did the serious on what
is green architecture with the
goethe-institut we had four siscaly
already here and process came again this
year with the Eco Graham conference and
now i think this cooperation is really
working extremely well and I think I
hope I can continue like working with
Columbia in this way so Andrew career
was actually born in England and studied
at the Polytechnic in London and later
at the architecture association AAA in
London and moved to Alabama and he will
tell us more about what it is exactly
what it means to live in New Bern
Alabama later and ten years ago so in
two thousand and he was there as a a
thesis professor first when Semel mok/pa
was still there and still around but
soon after when Sam will mark be the
founder of roll studio he founded it in
1993 died in 2001 Andrew took over add
as the director of verse to do and what
I find when I look back into the history
of rural studio I mean it's a it's a
legendary design built studio for
students and has influenced so many
other schools in America like with this
program what I find is so interesting
that it was first so much related with
like the figure of Sam amake and then
now with interfere it has like changed
in many ways the shift and direction but
still is like so so important and has
come up with in delay and some in the
latest years with some more more
systematic ideas than before so starting
with like individual projects and then
now coming up with an idea which I found
so important the 20k house which is in
the exhibition because I wanted to focus
on an idea that has more than an impact
on one family or one little community
but has maybe an potential of an impact
into like maybe other communities and
maybe other countries so this this
pedagogy of hands on the is like still
ongoing is still still there but it has
become in has got into a new direction
andrew is not only the director of our
studio and also the thesis professor but
it's also designed and supervised
exhibitions in many cities and I was
very happy that like Andrew who did
design exhibitions was not coming up
with an exhibition design for the show
in moma because like we have this with
other architects that came in with their
proposals and they had already that
exhibition design ready how they wanted
to have it presented moma so we had a
great cooperation in that and I think it
turned out as a great success now also
in the connection with the other
projects in MoMA and interfere with Rose
studio one I don't name the other prices
in the words but I want to let him speak
in 2006 the rough and raw s can award as
a first American and I think especially
the Earth's kind of word is like very
important because it's since the
beginnings it's an award for
sustainability and social sustainability
word that has now become more interest
in the audience so Andrew please is
yours
thank you I'm sorry I'm a bit of a mess
tonight Oh sort of dizzy and queasy or
something so so if I if I collapse in
the middle of it just it'll be okay I i
even i went to the restroom and realized
that I torn a huge great hole in my
shirt so Jesus I'm just falling to bits
and then then today ten years I think
like 10 years ago this year after mock
be dyed the architectural league invited
me to come up here to do a lecture and
they put me in the Hudson and I'm in the
hudson hotel thank you for the fantastic
hotel but as a as a kind of peasant from
the woods it's just it's frightening in
that you know I mean I I and I remember
the first time going and I couldn't
figure out how to flush the toilet
because it was a phillips dark toilet
and this time at least they changed the
toilets out so he can place the toilet
but y'all y'all need to laugh at my joke
sir i'm going to bugger off okay thank
you to thank you the moma andres and
margo particularly fantastic a huge
honor for us to be involved in such an
exhibit with so many serious folks and
we're just kind of fooling around in the
woods of west alabama so it's really
wonderful to have it legitimized in that
manner and also to Ben and Lucia for
getting me here today any excuse to get
the hell out of Hale County you know
I'll I i'll get i'll get out of there I
don't know how do you turn oh well y'all
this is the kind of the mythical founder
of the rule studio program it's godlike
figure it's it's his legendary the
things that he's done the people that
he's known and it's it's quite
it's quite a it's quite a task living up
to this myth and I knew him very
differently I lived with him for about
three years and saw the real guy and he
was he was a huge amount of fun and a
huge amount of energy and I think about
killed himself doing what he did and it
was a huge shock to us to lose him I
hope tonight sir everybody says y'all
you need to stop showing that slide and
stop talking about the early work well I
you know it's okay so it's a it's an
amazing body of work I hope you'll agree
it's an amazing body of work tonight I
hope that I can show you the sort of
level of energy and passion that goes
into the work it's as an intensity to
the place that I think I delight in it's
why i live in the middle of nowhere with
a bunch of 23 year olds it it's really
exhilarating and i hope that i can kind
of dis melt dispel a few of the myths i
know i find most of the documentaries
and the books and most of the things
that have been written about the studio
to relative really they try to overly
simplify it it's a really i find it an
extremely complicated place and I I kind
of run around most of the time trying to
sweep things up and tidy up the edges
because it is so complicated but I hope
tonight i can i can get dispel some of
those myths a little bit i am an insider
and an outsider I've got a silly accent
but I've been there about 11 years so I
i know it reasonably well i hope that
what i will show you tonight is some a
series of projects that i hope a born of
necessity all of the projects that we do
were asked to get involved with we don't
we don't helicopter them in it's not
those trying to tell people how to live
their lives and for me that's extremely
important
the work that you'll see all of all the
physical stuff that you see tonight is
all paid for by donations and grants so
if there's any rich folks out there and
you fancy I've got rich parents I'm
happy for y'all to come and write me a
check at the end of this and I hope that
I can I can also show you a little bit
about the place the people in the place
are extremely important that's why I
take the luxury of taking you to Hale
County a little bit at the start of this
lecture those other folks that have
already been on this journey forgive me
but I think it's important to just kind
of reflect on the place a little bit
otherwise you'll miss understand it I
hope also it offers up a positive and
constructive critique on how we make
architecture and how we teach and train
architects I'm not certainly not
standing here tonight saying that
everybody has to have a rule studio but
I think educates architectural education
is going in particular directions today
and I think that we should all be aware
of that and be part of those choices are
being made you should be capable of
defining your career path from the way
that you work and I don't think we're as
aggressive and proactive as we can be so
and I hope also that there's a little
bit of a suggestion of some some rigor I
I think in the past the sort of the
sense of not being a few students
messing around in the woods custody can
I find that quite offensive I'm I work
down there 24 hours a day seven days a
week trying to really do and figure out
the right thing to do not what shall we
do what can we do what could we do but
what is the right thing to do and so we
take it really separate really seriously
I I'm going to just read a few things at
the beginning of this cuz there's always
some grown-up stuff that I always forget
to talk about so just as a kind of an
introduction and I'm going to try and
get through it as quickly as possible so
y'all because I was warned that you York
New York
don't have a very long attention span
and that y'all might walk walk out so
I'm going to keep it fast and
entertaining hopefully okay so this is
mark being big fat white guy from
Mississippi with the unpolitical e
correct nickname we're all studio is an
undergraduate educational program it's
part of the five year bachelor of
architecture auburn university now in
its 17-year 17th year it was set up by
DK Ruth and Samuel mock be as a response
to two things first of all was a desire
to have a more hands-on approach for
architecture students and second there
was an it there is an interest in
looking at the definitive rural house
just very quickly so you all know where
I come from today this is this is the
sort of the deep south y'all are up
there somewhere where were we actually a
right about here at the bottom end of
the Appalachian mountain trail okay and
that what's interesting about that is
that it we also inhabit an area called
the black belt and that the black it's
called the black belt cost not because
there's a whole bunch of black folks
living there but because of the type of
soil that emanates through that area and
it's actually because of the Appalachian
this Appalachian Mountain Formation
range yeah range range will do sorry I'm
losing it I all intimidated me because
Columbia is such a famous place you know
so lots of this red plate stuff comes
through here and so it's called the
black belt right you got that and a
couple of things to think about and you
know first and foremost this fantastic
map which shows you that Alabama screwed
up at some point in the very very near
past got rid of their most you know
valuable piece of real estate along the
way I mean you know somebody needs their
head seeing too but just to just to take
you there so there's a triangle as a
civil rights triangle of Birmingham
Selma and Montgomery we're in a place
called New Bern which is
West Alabama a town of about 200 230
people when the students there the
university's over here on the east side
the civil rights triangle we have to
deal with every day I mean it's an it's
a matter of fact of our everyday
existence it's a it's a very potent and
emotional issue for everybody we can we
can talk all night about the impact that
that has on our students I think what's
nice from my point of view is that the
students don't bring baggage to this
discussion they're willing to work with
anybody and what happens in these sorts
of places is a lot awful lot of sort of
entrenched opinions and baggage that
stops people actually doing things right
so our students bring in almost an
innocence yes but a willingness to work
with everybody which i think is really
important the other thing to say is that
it's it's if you're thinking of setting
up a rural studio which some of you
might be what's interesting about this
map is that new burns over here and all
burns over here and it's a three hour
drive so essentially what that means is
that there's this sort of three our
distance between all those folks at a
university that are determined to stop
you out doing having any fun at all you
know the kind of Provost's and vice
chancellors and deans and presidents all
those law if they get in their car we've
got at least got three hours to clear up
all the mess you know come on y'all
wakey wakey okay so this is this is the
chosen location Hale County in West
Alabama and it was an area that was very
well documented by James a AG in the
1930s this is actually main street
greensboro circa 1930s and if you look
at an image of greens were today there's
actually not an awful lot of difference
you know there's a slightly newer volvo
on the street and a coat of paint down
and a painted yellow stripe but life
moves very very slowly similarly this is
a sharecroppers home again serkan
1830s a walker evans photograph again
and this is Mason's been today and again
if I think what if Samuel mock me was
here and sort of legitimizing this show
in this conversation because of his deep
southern drawl rather than my stupid
English accent with occasionally all he
was profound 'add profoundly offended by
what he found in West Alabama the hale
county population is 16 is 16,000 out of
that population thirty-six percent lived
below the poverty line and a really
extraordinary forty-five percent of
children and below the poverty line and
that doesn't take me as a European with
a silly accent and who says you all to
sort of just find that extraordinary in
this kind of society country and with so
much wealth and so much richness but you
have that in your own backyard and again
is you know point made i guess it's also
a beautiful faith-based place and
religion is absolutely everywhere come
on y'all a slow at reading there's also
great evidence that they all old white
wealth the cotton wealth that there's
also this incredible poverty which can
can just look like you know the
archetypal images of sweat or Johnsburg
or wherever we expect those images to
come from what's changed a little bit
today even in the 10 years that I've
been there is that this kind of poverty
has disappeared and it's disappeared
behind the face of the faceless pneus of
trailer homes really crappily designed
and crappily built trailer homes so
there's less of the kind of shanty and
shark and do it floor but it's still
there it's just evolved slightly also in
front are incredible dignity i mean this
is alberto harris alberta brian this is
the client for the first house they're
all studio ever built a phenomenal lady
and I love this photograph
this is a kind of classic Tim hursley
photograph Shepherd Bryant turns his
back on Tim and said I'm not you're not
photographing me pal and then an Alberta
Tim captured this now Alberto has lost
at lost both of her limbs because of
diabetes and when I first met her what I
loved about Alberta was finding her and
she would she would have her hand around
her prosthetic leg and she'd wave around
the nephews and nieces who were walking
in and out as I it was like it was the
control stick or device to control her
kids right just so fantastic dignity I
mean could be really angry and really
disappointed at the world but not at all
the most delightful lovely lady and she
actually died three weeks ago suddenly
enough but so it's um it's a sense the
demise of cotton it's a landscape barely
sustain is the logging industry and more
recently the catfish industry what's
interesting about this and this is this
is actually an area of ponds very close
to New Bern where I live the same red
clay dirt that they used to purvey
cotton long you can actually dig a hole
in that dirt and you don't have to line
it out and you can actually put water in
there and then they throw a bunch of
catfish in there so it's the the dairy
farmers are really diversify into that
because they're not making enough money
in the dairy you see the beautiful red
clay but they're really trying to figure
out a way to make a living and
ironically enough that red clay is very
very difficult for us to build on
because it's expansive it expands and
contracts so if you ever want to do a
concrete slab you've got to super
thicken it or you've got a super
reinforce it the and again this is this
is what is this balanced with the dairy
farming is a sort of the predominant way
to make a living down there at the
moment it's also a really beautiful
place i have to say and you know the
evidence this is on the place called
folsom
beautiful old plantation real evidence
here of a sort of African carpentry just
you know as an architect you just kind
of died for this is beautiful cantilever
here the big overhang sensibly big roof
lift the building off the ground and the
things been here 130 years you know so
we look at those sorts of things every
day but this is far I think a beautiful
piece of architecture it's also a
society that has a rest on sunday unlike
unlike even me and y'all it's it's it's
nice to see people have some respect for
each other to get dressed up to take a
deep breath whether it's for spiritual
reasons or whatever but at least they
say okay we're going to have a day with
the family today we're going to it's not
going to be 24 hours seven days a week
and I somewhat I somewhat like that and
this is uh this is a guy called Jim with
a spoon this is a 14-point buck head
this is what they call sport in West
Alabama I don't know whether you are
considerate sport but he was so proud of
this image that he put this up inside
the gas station in in Greensboro as a
kind of a trophy not not the thing
itself but the photograph right so I
still the photograph but again of great
cultural differences I mean this is what
he just relax that's not what I do to
relax so you go you go you this is the
sort of landscape that you find in West
Alabama lots of deforestation one of the
issues that Alabama has is that the
predominantly owned by people who don't
live there when you want and they're
very powerful people people that are
important for example involved in the
newspaper industry so the taxation is
extremely low there if you ever want to
do anything about health or education
and you suggest rising it even a course
raising it even by a quarter of a
percent they start to lobby and
frightened everybody that's the end of
the world is nigh if you if you pay a
few dollars on sales tax or even on real
estate tax so it's the really vicious
circle poor education
leads to really poor decision-making
locally and it's a it's a tough it's a
tough thing to be and then you know this
is sort of low to middle income housing
not quite as bad as this but it's sort
of indicative of how long these things
last you it's real I mean it's this is a
sort of American genius quite frankly
you can you can go to one of these Lots
you can buy one of these things put a
down payment on it and next day it's
delivered and you get your dream home
the problem is that you're paying
through the nose you're paying really
exorbitant interest rates on it but you
get your dream home the next day right
so it's instant architecture as I was an
architect's it's very difficult to beat
that but the problem is that these
things are falling into the ground 25
years later and they've probably paid
three or four times what the value is so
it's very sad and really quite
exploitative so this this is not be on
Main Street in New Bern I would suggest
a sort of three fundamental things that
the kids the students get out of this
experience one is a sort of a very clear
exposure to the sort of arts and crafts
tradition of architecture the connection
between drawing and making and
understanding of the kind of the
implications of the drawn line the other
is an immersion in a very very small
rural community that's full of gossip
and everybody knows what everybody else
is doing so there's an intensity that
art and then on top of that they also
have to work in teams and I think it's a
you know I hope that's why we all exist
to kind of work with each other play
with each of a be with each other and I
I think that we don't really give them
any lessons in how to work together they
just sort of get together like cuts and
start to fight and then begin to figure
it out but I think it's a fantastically
important part of their education but it
is all team building this is the world
headquarters of the rule studio the
Morris aunt house this is where the
third-year students live these are
called the pods these are the studio had
to build this at its beginning to give
accommodation to the younger students
because they were already paying rent
on the main campus so very pragmatic on
the other hand there they're built these
are the sort of the first thesis
projects so this is architecture
students who are getting the chance to
build on my goodness I've been
architecture school for years and I'm
going to just show you everything I've
learned and so they they literally vomit
it you know I mean it's got every trick
and every gizmo in the book they're
beautiful they're beautiful little
dwellings don't get me wrong but I think
you know they they are what they are and
it's the sort of classic hopefully the
kind of classic live work environment
you are but I hope that people take care
of it I think that there's there's a
hopefully a culture of living where you
live and also taking care of it this is
this is some in the Sun you know
certainly in the beginning there was a
reputation and again a characterization
of the rule studio as the great
scavengers and recyclers this is a sort
of classic example that mock be was very
proud of this is reverse Tail County
license plates making the cladding for
what he called the the
composting toilet down in a New Bern and
he always accused actually Frank Gehry
of stealing this idea for the Guggenheim
Museum so this is where I used to live
this is a very early photograph of me
but we were given this building well
actually bought it for three thousand
dollars that's nearly given I suppose
this is what it looks like today my
young staff live in this so we've got a
series of buildings discreetly tucked
into New Bern we're not trying to be
Marfa Texas or anything like that I hope
New Bern is nuber and it's not kind of
rural studio Disneyland but we have to
try and be as discreet as we possibly
can be and then this is downtown New
Bern yes this this is where the students
design all together this is the great
red barn that we took over in 2001 and
the the the owner said y'all
I'd love you to use it but you really
you know clearly he was frightened of
what the heck we might do to it cover it
with flying sticks or something and he
said you can't please don't touch the
outsides and you're joking man it's
beautiful why would we change it so
we've sort of changed it inside although
we didn't need to change it inside
upstairs and inhabited it and so it's
right in downtown nobody else would use
that building people wandering off the
streets come and see what we're doing
and it it feels like we're helping new
bern have a little bit of a center
reinforcing the the tout the the post
office and gb woods grocery store this
is Francis Sullivan who's calls herself
the postmaster not the postmistress she
looks after a number of our kids and
really has grown incredibly close to all
of our students as they go through each
year and this is this is Henry who
unfortunately has had to just recently
move into sheltered housing he did live
across the road from us but I always
enjoyed this photograph because I was
really intrigued by his diet of orange
juice and colt 45 and so as a teacher
you get to you really don't know what
you're going to place each day it's I
can be help raising some steel I can
also be working in the cold in the red
barn sketching on the wall there's we've
we've done a lot with the building i
think somebody in the audience is in
this photograph maybe maybe somewhere
with this is this is sort of our design
space it's terribly hot in summer and
terribly cold in winter it's sort of a
we don't want it to be like all one we
don't want it to be like the easy design
studio but it's probably getting
slightly ridiculous at the moment it it
needs a little TLC but it's a lovely
place to design and work we've been very
lucky over the lust at least ten years
really since mot be die to have a series
of guys and gals who have become our
consultants and
we really are go-to guys all pro not pro
bono work engineers from new york and
chicago and london environmental
engineers really smart guys who come and
help us because they love it and so i
can rely on them as a sort of extended
teaching arm if you like because there
aren't any resources to teach to bring
more teachers and professors in these
are these are the most important guys at
the royal studio the prison labor that
we have this used to be my my office I
now have a really kind of wussy honda
fit you know that's all politically
correct and really small and
fuel-efficient and I just you know this
thing just died but it was it was a
brute and I really enjoyed being map
showing it you know now I feel I feel
emasculated now so anyway and we have
these we have inmates from the local
prison camp that come out and help work
on our property and honestly they're
much more interesting than this students
quite honestly though so oh come on wake
up projects are I think the kind of
lousy title that I gave to the talk
tonight a local architect or something
it all of the projects you'll see
tonight are within a 25-mile radius of
New Bern really from a very practical
point of view how do you manage this
stuff how do you travel the least so we
were we're working in four and five
counties as a sort of a summary of who's
at the studio were typically running at
about 32 students officially 44
unofficially because we have these
thesis students who agree to come for
two semesters and nicely end up staying
from 12 months to two years to do these
probably slightly heroic bigger
community projects so there's 12 to 16
younger students typically they've done
charity home that's been tried completed
in about a year we've got typically
three to four public pretty major public
projects going on at the same time and
then we've got the outreaches at the
moment working on the 20k house and
they're a group of students that we want
to supplement the Auburn community with
our community of architects with a
little bit of life a little bit of
foreignness you know somebody else that
we don't know anything about so i don't
know if that and this is this is a
certificate program anybody from outside
Auburn can apply to this and come and be
part of the Royal studio typically three
to four students and you know that in
the history of I was like this
photograph because it implies you know
democracy and cooperation and
conversation up you know in the history
of the studio or obviously the
essentially the program sort of made its
name by doing single-family homes the
students do indeed get to design these
things and build them they work with the
clients and they really try to
understand what it is that the client
really needs through models or
three-dimensional work I mean obviously
these folks have really never spoken to
an architect before have no idea what
they're even talking about but and then
the luxury of it all is that and
probably unlike anything that you could
do in New York City but they really do
get to jump on the backhoe and put the
put them put the plumbing in and put the
roof on and put the electric in and all
of that stuff so there's a fantastic
experience that they get there just to
lift that two-by-four and understand how
heavy it is to lift that four by eight
sheet of plywood and understand how
difficult it is for the tradesmen to put
it in the house it's really important so
you know from the beginning I think you
know some your mock be was probably
smart enough to know that at least
initially he needed to get some work out
there that was really good and that
people would acknowledge as being good
and I think frankly I think some bows
name is all over that is his hand is all
over this this is the first house but
the studio did
for Alberta and chef that I showed you
earlier and of classic southern porch
the straw bale infill the little wagon
wheels on the back to accept the
extended family terrific relationship
with the client but the client lives
with it not as it even if it's a piece
of artwork it is you know it's their
home there's the detritus of everyday
life and a phenomenal relationship
evolved between sambo and Lee and these
two clients I mean to just you you could
not believe it the in this part of
Alabama but that I mean I remember her
stories of you know why is this white
guy I don't believe this white guy he's
not really going to come and build as a
house and so and we living there and
being part of that community what's
allowed us to do is things like this
this is this is 18 months ago we went
back the the two elderly folks that were
living here had really not been able to
look after it and so we went back we
threw all of the studio at the house and
we just gave it a good old cleaning and
a coat of paint and tipped it upside
down and now the granddaughter of
Alberta and chef is living in it so I I
you know it's it's a it's a good feeling
to know that that somebody else is
making use of that and that it's not
falling into the ground and it's not
just a good feeling that I think it but
they were not you know because of their
age they simply weren't able to give it
the TLC that it did not deserved more
recently in terms of the studio was our
third year students have been looking at
the single-family house there's some
question in the studio at the moment as
to what exactly the third year should be
looking at but about 18 months ago we
completed this house which was a
different type of model from the porch
the classic southern porch it is a porch
house but it's also a study of a
courtyard house this is that is what we
call it the cedar house it's totally
it'll erupt maniacally in in sort of one
by two cedar with this great public
porch and there's Rosalie Turner sitting
on the front porch because she loved
she's a very social lady this is the the
courtyard that we made with these
vertical cedar slots so that there was
some privacy and then when you were in
certain angles you could see through it
to be able to communicate with her
neighbor and cedar laid into a concrete
backyard because she said I don't want
any you know I don't want any lawn to
mow you know give me some concrete back
there so that's why the surface is as
hard as it is and then that's the
interior and all of the wood was
scavenged from a barn we the students
took a fantastic barn down that was
donated to us and all of the all of the
sheathing and the trustees that you see
were made of an old barn and the floor
so quite a nice house I think and of
course there's a nice house Jesus you
don't say nice house do you at Columbia
and you know also the reputation of the
studio for taking sort of recycled and
found materials rightly or wrongly used
as an opportunity for a number of the
houses this is this is carpet we we were
invited by interface to build an
exhibition they came to us and said we
want you to use some cardboard bales the
image that you've got on the poster
tonight we want to use some cardboard
bales to exhibit some of our work and
talk of some of the raw studio work and
talk about some of your work and we're
like what the hell is carpet got to do
with it sorry his cardboard got to do
with this so we are we call them up and
said send us some of your castoffs from
the carpet and this is what they sent us
these fantastic huge great bales of yarn
that are actually used for dashboards on
automobiles so it's the it's the
furthest tough that you find on a
dashboard if you've ever turn your
dashboard
look on the other side of it it's for
insulation so I spent my summer with my
head in a trash compactor making these
kind of big fluffy dog things like the
size of a straw bale and and then we
stacked them and made this 22 inch solid
wall of yarn and inserted these metal
frames into it to display the models and
then as a result of that mock be sort of
captured their attention and said go
annual give us some money so we can
build a house and we'll build out of
carpet and the cut the challenge was
could we build a house out of carpet
probably not with the yarn because of
course you know that would be silly but
we but we we got sillier and we decided
to build it out of tile and these tile
these carpet tiles are the conventional
tile that often used in to
institutionally in a place like this
maybe not this stuff but these these
were seconds they had off gas for seven
years they were very clean they sat in a
warehouse nobody knew what to do with
them and so we took we essentially took
72,000 of them and stacked them one on
top of the other and built a house for
Lucy and SAT a ring beam all the way
around the top of the wall and tightened
it down and then attached the roof to
that so there actually is a there are
columns going up through the wall we
didn't expect that the wall would
support the roof but there's sort of a
safety issue for the half of course and
then that's how the house ended up
looking it was an interesting house
because it started off in the lifetime
of sambo and then sambo died sort of at
Christmas and and the sort of the team
split a little bit and and you can never
guess that one team was over here and
the other team was over here and it they
forgot i would suggest it got a tub
competitive so you know and it lost its
screened-in porch which I don't think
mock be would have allowed them to do
but it's a really interesting house they
love it it's really changed their lives
totally this guy AJ his personality and
performance that school has gone through
the roof this is a family used to living
12 rooms right and they're a big family
in more ways than one you know
so the problem is something like this is
that you you give them you work with
them on this house right and then what
do they do they run off and they go to
the furniture guy the local furniture
guy who allows them to take this
furniture on the Nevernever so they they
fill the house with the most
ridiculously expensive furniture because
this is what though they're all sitting
on in daytime TV or something you know
so so they put themselves in debt after
you tried to help them out of it so so
and of course it allows it allowed us to
kind of access to those kinds of
communities at the same time with the
material exploration formerly the
student studio started to and I don't
know whether it was by accident or not
but again in this sort of process of
scavenging a couple of really I mean
very well known in remarkable places
came out the glass chapel in Mason's
band made of windshields scavenge from
Chicago and established as a kind of
fish skin sitting on the top of the
around Earth wall really beautiful but
it's it's sad because it's it's in a
community that doesn't know how to look
after the building and its really a kind
of it it's a difficult one for the
studio to live with because the kids
locally trash it and there's nobody
there willing to kind of take it over
because the person that owned the land
has died and it's you know what do you
do do you I don't know pick it up and
bring it to moma what you do with this
thing goes because when people come and
visit this that pissed off the people
locally because they don't think they
care about it and the people who are
local are too busy trying to survive
worrying about whether or not the
windshields are dirty you know so but at
the same time well a little bit earlier
was the the really remarkable yangtze
tire chapel made out of 900 rammed
stacked and filled with dirt tires
covered in pink concrete mean a
remarkably for mature piece but also a
piece that was built on private
and so now the problem is that the owner
died you know when you're starting a
program like this I guess you choose
your battles you jump in bed with some
people that you don't end up you know
don't end up coming through this is
built on private property people people
because of the person that was working
with us at the time died somebody else
inherited it and so now nobody can go
and see this and this is a really huge
shame because it's a it's a phenomenal
piece the pulpit actually sort of hangs
over a sort of a ravine so when you're
when the preacher is in the pulpit here
it's as if he's sort of standing in
media and it's just a phenomenal piece
of architecture this is the view back so
really since some you might be dyed
we've had a remarkable number of
requests to get involved with projects i
think we've also taken on and off I
thought of a different form of recycling
it's not the sort of license plates
tires what can you do with this pile of
stuff it's well how can we save this
building and in this case we came and
looked at this building and we owned a
nard about it and ultimately we tore it
down and said what we'll do with this
one is we'll take this down we'll take
it down piece by piece and we ended up
using 75% of it in the new building so
we took the time and the care we even
built them a little what you call a
little chapel because you've imagined
you tear someone's church down they're
going to go somewhere else so we needed
to make them a little chapel where they
could come and have their Sunday
services together so that when the
church was being rebuilt that they had
somewhere to go but this was all Earth's
taking the time and the care and the
attention for them to understand that
all of that materials being regenerated
into a new church the church was moved
up closer to the cemetery you can see
the cemetery reflected in the windows
and and so this is that this is the
feeling that you get when you're sitting
in the nave of the church here's the my
graveyard and it's it's there's this
relationship really i mean you know
where you're going to end up when you're
sitting in this place now this is a
fantastic image these these these guys
again this is this is that again the
reuse of a building that probably nobody
else would have done this was a an
abandoned school building a group called
the rural heritage foundation wanted to
occupy this we found that they had a
hundred and ninety thousand dollars they
were actually going to I think get
ripped off and what we ended up doing
was was a really two and a half face
project we gave them a big old sign
because it was it was set back from a
main road so it needed to waive its arms
a little bit we made them a stage so
it's a celebration of rural heritage and
particularly the heritage of rural West
Alabama there's a big peple pepper jelly
eating a pepper jelly festival in which
they have watermelon eating contests and
they even have the Alabama Elvis shows
up and we we put in a ironically enough
in their program that they had got this
money for they didn't have a gift shop
it was like well are y'all going to
survive you know anywhere to sell your
stuff and so we were able this is
actually the first piece we did we
inserted the kind of me see and glass
box into the old school building gave
them a pepper jelly display wall that
they could walk around and this is in
the sunset in the evening it's a really
fantastic color that comes through here
idea was stolen from my land Blackwell a
little bit from his beehive thing but
this is damn sight better there you go
and it's why me seein well cus that all
of that folk art stuff is just it's
noisy and colorful and all over the
place so you don't need to fight that we
worked with hero to take this old
dilapidated storefront and turn into
this this is all donated glass donated
Pella windows just a kind of a loft a
very simple stripping out of the
existing building don't build too many
new walls in there because their program
may change we worked with the low
schools Perry County Board of Education
had nowhere for the bad kids to go to so
they were deliberately getting expelled
so they could go home and so we turned
this into this and just it was a very
simple SI in sort of a plywood module we
one of the most successful we've done is
a senior center in Akron turn this into
this again reuse the buildings that
probably nobody else would bother
whether they probably just tear them
around tell them down this is
greensborough our county seat the kind
of the capital of Hale County ironically
enough they had they had had an l-shaped
hospital and the architect the brilliant
architect put an extension on the L
shape and came almost he didn't complete
the doughnut right so they couldn't go
all the way around without going outside
and it's like you didn't complete the
doughnut you know what why didn't you
make the courtyard so so we made the
courtyard and what essentially could and
you know we weren't able to touch the
the walls or for a variety of legal
reasons but we certainly made a place
that the staff and the patients can come
and enjoy and a covered walkway to
connect the the complete circle whoops
oh you can't miss these guys these guys
sensibly enough decided to work with New
Bern and build a fire station come Town
Hall this guy's in the audience tonight
I mean just a big shoulders civic
project the first building in New both
for 110 years wow it's got to be good
convince them that the pattern of New
Bern was very urban although it's you
know it's a very rural place so push the
fire station up to the street celebrate
those fire trucks you can see how urban
the rest of these are right off at the
street age so we followed that pattern
two guys and two girls built listing in
around two years that's will brothers I
don't know if layers in less
and then we had a fantastic opening and
all of New Bern and just about all of
West Alabama showed up and we at weird
that I never forget this they were
decided at six thirty at night to have
the fire trucks turn their lights on and
the sirens are going to go off and then
we would lift the front the front door
would go up and they come out and
everybody would cheer and what happened
was the front door came up to about here
and it got stuck and and all you could
see where the students like like moving
around going and anyway so it was
it's the one thing you've got to get
right on a firehouse really in it but it
was actually the one thing we didn't
build so but it's it's at this is a big
south facing wall that's covered in poly
ghoul and then see the slots so the high
summer sun is controlled by the seed of
slats low winter Sun allows it to get in
there stop the fire it's freezing heat
up the concrete floor no insulation yada
yada yada but it but a very I mean it's
a it's a new ones very proud of it were
proud of it and then it's moved on from
these sort of bigger community projects
to some projects that have got some
structural thought behind it or more
rational structural thought or more
deliberate structural thought this is
got a lamellar structure kind of
beginning to have a dialogue locally as
to how you could build long span
structures without using steel so much
so this is all built using a jig this is
all two by sixes standard dimension
lumber that you can get your local
supply store and you just bolt the whole
thing together and you build it on top
of that jig the jig wheels down the
grade beams you build a section at a
time so you build a concrete grade beams
you wheel the jig into it you build on
top of it this amount right and then you
lower it you move it along lift it up
build it again the other ya're ya're so
you can build it to Mississippi and this
is the Hale County Animal Shelter I mean
naturally ventilated underfloor heating
fantastic partnership with the county
and then we took that idea I said to
them look that jig cost us so much money
we've got to use it again so I said we
can do the boys and girls club in Akron
if we use the jig so I forced them to
use a jig so the boys and girls club in
Akron has as I slightly distorted lamela
that almost looks as if it's falling
down but we rolled it over so this is
the lamella from this point down to here
literally tipped over on its side and
what it does is it allows you to play
basketball in there so it lifted it up
and rolled it and this lock this thing
here is just a big old box but
essentially is the sheer wall for that
thing to stop it falling over you know
so and it well it's a little bit more
complicated than that but it deals with
the buckling it deals with the buckling
in these columns ok and that's a big old
structural gutter which is really cool
so this is the basketball that's the
entrance this is a basketball court
that's the entrance this is it at night
this is the kids that opening it's it's
up and running now we're all very proud
of it this was the opening party with
the mayor we've had a series of Park
projects that have allowed us to kind of
do with projects as phases so how can
you do a big project but in a series of
small phases this is perri lakes park
thus the poorest County in our part of
West Alabama they got 110 thousand
dollars to read to open the park they
asked us to be the project architects so
this is a kind of process that the
students go through just like you all do
bring the site to the studio kind of
three-dimensional stuff so they can
communicate with each other there are
lots of models physical modeling then
you get out on site and you test
something and you say well how you know
I'm suggesting it's 30 feet high what
the hell does that look like in this
space so as the architect likes to use
privilege to go to the site and test it
and be on site 24 hours a day seven days
a week understand the the climate lots
of details the studio is accused of not
doing it very much of this we do a
terrific amount of this so we don't
waste money then we make mock-ups of
them to test them
we do not very kind of Columbia looking
renderings no blobbies in here at all
it's just trees look like trees and then
then Steve Burdines comes at Christmas
and he says what the hell are you doing
why are you putting it here and we have
our reviews on site and then they get to
present to the client and this is where
we rehearse rehearse religiously because
if what comes out of your mouth is
ridiculous it really doesn't matter how
good those drawings are how do you
orchestrate that room how do you
communicate with them how do you make
sure they're close enough to it to
understand it so young wasted your time
it's fantastic this is a an amazing kind
of client body of probate judge and
mayor and county engineer and all sorts
their folks then you get these cells on
the front of the local newspaper the
kind of they were after getting seeded
donated so they got some cedar trees
donated then they went in the ground
they used the bark from when we milled
the trees they used all of the bark on
the inside of the form work for the
footings so when you take the form work
off the bark residue is left on the pond
the footings and then you then you stand
there and watches the local contractor
puts the heavy stuff up and then you say
well this is 32 feet up in the air
and the royal studio of course insists
on on no hard hats or safety equipment
and you know fantastic discussions about
the process of building you know if
you're going to if you want to put metal
on here do you need to put plywood under
here to secure that metal to so it
doesn't oil can how are you going to do
that is it you know and if you're going
to put plywood on the underside of there
it's sort of reverse of the process you
really want to always be building on top
so they agree to put the plywood up it
does buckle but I think it in the manner
that it buckles it gives off a very
beautiful light so they leave the mayor
came to the opening the kind of
reflected in direct
is fantastic you can see they were put
and here's the kind of buckling I'm
talking about that they like that so and
then the sort of the seed of platform
wraps up and over so there's two planes
that float this is the kissing bench
these two guys were caught kissing and
then this is our for student saying that
Andres is the number one curator in the
entire world and then Hurricane Ivan hit
and unfortunately this big old baby here
went right through there and smash the
end of it we got ten thousand dollars to
rebuild it from FEMA though so and then
we were asked to build restrooms and
they they like the pavilion so much they
said don't don't we won't spend it on
that fifty thousand dollars on a
prefabricated restroom we want you to
build it so we did for rest three
restrooms the three most ridiculous
pooping experiences in the United States
of America there's a tall toilet the
mound Tyler and the long toilet this is
the view from a John in the toll toilet
then there's the mount the the long
toilet with these two arms going out
that go out and they grab this tree so
you can sit and look at the tree when
you're on the John and then this is this
a haha deed mount toilet you get this
very nice horizontal and you can sit
there and imagine shooting zahara she
runs across and then are so they ask we
we thought of we're running out of money
and we brought money to the table to
build this bridge because they wanted us
to build a birding tower and in another
part of the part but we had to get
across a creek to get to the building
the birding tower so we built this sort
of hanging bridge it so it's a very kind
of clear here's the structural support
here's the tie-downs leaving cantilever
this sits here like the kind of st.
Louis Arch and really that's what was
built the sorts of drawings that we do
with our consultants then we built it up
the road from the from where it was
going to be sited we put it on trailer
axles list then that's the old geezer
here running
on the road trying to hold that they
structure up off the floor to stop it
bouncing on the ground and you imagine
with that that trust is going through
much more stress than than it would in
any situation when it's actually in
position and then they got this crane
donated for the weekend lifted it all
into place and then put a roof over the
top of it well there you go there it
sits and that takes you to the tower
which you know they had wanted a birding
tower and some smart ass said to us why
don't you go and get one of those fire
towers because the DP commissioning all
those fire towers was one of those
moments and so the kids ran off and got
this donated for I think like ten
dollars but that was the crux of the
problem was and that was my oh
moment because I suddenly realized that
they'd have to take it down and build it
and so the project became a reality so
we might my prerequisite was to them
you've got to go off and get the the
most the you've got to go off and get
certified as tower erectors and d
constructors and of course lo and behold
they did and they learnt on the tower
they took the tower down and they took
it away and had it piece by piece had it
rigged alvin eyes at safety training but
they they started at the top and took it
down they didn't learn from the ground
and you know and so they're all very
sort of macho but it we we put it into
the ground with helical anchors no
concrete they did this all themselves
boot this beautiful boardwalk that
floats up to it and then you see these
great views and then you find the tower
and so they rebuilt the tower and the
helical anchors allowed them to put it
right next to the ecotone they did
fantastic handrails new handrails and
closures but the positioning it was all
about the positioning of this thing
that's the architecture of this thing on
that these amazing views 100 100 feet up
over the swamp
you can look out over that landscape and
there it disappears into the and am i
okay yeah okay all right as a result of
that experience of this kind of one
project after another enabled us to say
yes to lions park the local community
established the committee with all sorts
of cast of characters on this committee
but it they came to us in 2005 and said
can you help us remake out our park it's
been done in an ad hoc manner we think
it can be much better so we have sort of
to this day we have numerous community
meetings this is what the part looked
like sort of a lot of it had fallen into
disrepair all of the home plates were in
different places so there was no genius
loci so the initial thing we did was I'm
sorry about the projection but we turned
it into a hub-and-spoke so the first
stage was six ball fields with a
hub-and-spoke around the pavilion which
is an existing pavilion keep the cars
out of the park let's have some
discipline area photographs of it and so
the first stage was these back stops and
the regrading of the fields the students
took down the existing got some more
donated ended up getting a hundred
thousand dollars from baseball tomorrow
to do all the backstops and a lot of the
work so we we did new trashcan
containers new benches new backstops all
of this stuff so you can hit it with a
baseball bat and you can't break it
graphic lines in the landscape to
camouflage water and electrical
connections and also to try and give the
landscape just a little bit of three
dimensionality or light life new gates
that the people are kind of falling in
love with they come and get themselves
photographs all sorts of folks from the
community enjoying the gates we built
them restrooms that take the water off
the roof so the water these are these
culverts all connected together the
water rises inside
and it's the brown water flushes of the
toilets which are inside these podium
place come home when they call it tilt
up concrete panels so there's a tilt up
concrete panel restrooms all pressurized
by the water from the roof pressurizing
the system Prison toilets next step was
make a make a new space in the park
because it was very successful so we
needed some more room we wanted a
concession stand and we were playing
with this idea of having a mouth that
you bought food out of and and we
couldn't figure out we had this mouth
like this and we couldn't figure out how
to do this stuff and my plumber friend
showed up from Chicago and he said y'all
why don't you just make it move and
we're all set you're right so so it
moves right it opens and it closes so
that's it closed that's it open that's
then building it or being photographed
building it and that's it in the site
and it's lifted up so that the
volunteers whose children are playing
can see and they get the kind of the
vest the best view you can see it in
Grand Central sorry this is a crap image
but this is a skate park plan the series
what we call the skate trail coming
together and making a kind of genius
loci here so that the it's not a big
blob of concrete got twenty five
thousand dollars from tony hawk from san
francisco so it connects to the front
edge kind of here you go this is better
so it's a series of sort of sidewalk
sighs horse that are that size so that
the students can build it themselves
they become expert in finishing concrete
we could help them pour it and they
finished it so these are the sorts of
renderings not quite colombia and then
these are these are our client the young
local kids which is a very different you
know client group than we've ever worked
with before this is the process of
testing whether or not we could do this
every concrete skateboard
every skateboard contractor and concrete
comes right to said you can't do this
and conceptually it's four inches of
concrete that uses dirt to make its form
work so it's like putting a piece of
paper down on the dirt and it folds up
and down and it's always just four
inches and so you make little things
like that which is a kind of a kick up
and so you're able to see the back of
that piece of cut not that concrete for
this is then finishing the bowl these
three guys just became absolutely
fantastic concrete finishers this is it
opening again an amazing bringing
another client into the park corten
steel grinding whatever you call them
place the grind on so it disappears
externally it disappears and then when
you get into it you find it and at many
places you just see the kind of kids
jumping you don't actually understand
what they're jumping from I suppose and
then also in the part we're building a
playground out of 2,800 galvanized steel
barrels that we like in agglomeration
individually they're not that pretty but
together they look pretty so this is a
mock-up we were making a roof to to
shade the maze or making a 1800 bowel
maze for kids to run in and around
swings slides all sorts of stuff and
this is a test to show the client what
were hell we're talking about that's the
kind of shaded space that it makes
underneath it these are the images of it
but it's going to look like so there's
this big floating roof to provide shade
and then all sorts of different things
going on inside it wow that's a
spaceship can I go and play in it and
yeah so and then then the ground falls
away and makes so that maze runs out
horizontally in the ground falls away
and you have this kind of fantastic
subterranean space as well and then
finally this 20k thing finally you know
it's it's great for the studio because I
think it's that it's an opportunity for
us to be very clear that we're not
taking food off the table of the
profession nobody else would enter into
five years of designing a house for
twenty thousand dollars no architect no
contract and no builder could afford to
do this so each year we design a house
we build it we let somebody live in it
we watch how they've lived in it it's
it's raised an awful lot of interest for
whatever reason it's this sort of
response to what is it to be affordable
you see all these trendy affordable
explanations on the Front's of magazines
and it's 150 thousand dollars so we have
given ourselves a discipline of of
twenty thousand dollars twelve and a
half thousand dollars in material
seventy five hundred dollars in labor
and profit and you've got to build it in
three weeks and this is this is Dave's
house that's in that's in the exhibit 10
foot high ceilings screened-in porch he
can run it for thirty-five dollars a
month and it's you know adding that sexy
but it is every piece of wood in there
is thought about and talked about and
pushed to its limit and the most recent
one is our max house it's interesting
that this one is a sort of a shotgun
forum and I don't know how we've ended
up like this but they're very
historically relevant forms you know
there were shotgun forms and they were
dogtrot forms and I think it's this sort
of you know you're working with a
limited supply material this is the
lumber you've got how far can you span
minimal foundations yada yada yada so
here's the shotgun kitchen in the center
sleeps this side lives that side the
porch is pushed in and so there's sort
of two models floating around and we're
negotiating with regions bank to begin
to fund the next step of release
these things so that they get built the
way that we want them to be built
finally honestly finally the studio also
ethically has started to understand that
we live in the middle of a forest in
Alabama we want to kind of release
ourselves from Lowe's and Home Depot use
and one of the questions in the in the
forestry industry at the moment is what
to do with the crappy trees because
every 12 10 to 15 years you have to you
have to take these out so that the other
ones grow nice and tall and straight
what can you do with those at the moment
they use for paper pulp they're also
used for fence posts and they burn them
no one's reading newspapers anymore
they're all sitting there with our
laptops so what can you do with this and
so we've challenged ourselves to take
that material and think about how what
what particular forms and manners can we
use it in our long-term aim is to use it
in housing we had an initial try that
was a quite honestly a failure ended up
with a ridiculously expensive joint then
we started looking much you know more
where the word is we looked at it in
another way and and you know you cut
this tree down and you bend it and it's
it's because it's new and wet and it's
just been cut down it bends more easily
so you tie it and make a beam and so
suddenly you've got a beam that used to
be three or four inches and now it
actually has a structural capability of
that and so this is sort of conceptual
student diagram this is what they ended
up with we're working with the US
Forestry Service reap using this
material to rebuild some of the
infrastructure in okmulgee national
forest which is part of the Talladega
National Forest with the idea that
eventually will start to look enclosures
enclosures on how to build small houses
this was a second one stuff you don't
need to know about and then this is the
one that's going on this year it's a
hundred and eighty foot long bridge made
with a lattice trust the lattice is
Dowell together this is the
is the regional engineer for the Forest
Service looking at this so this is a
section this is a 15-foot section of
another of a writ of full section that
would be a 60 feet long so it's three
sections of 60 feet coming to a landing
point and the landing points are put in
with helical anchors and this has been
quite an engineering experience quite
honestly this bottom chord it's the the
wood is put into compression because
this wood is really no good you can't
make the joints intention so we figured
out a way to put that bottom code into a
compression using a hidden metal rod I'm
not very clear that that's particularly
structurally honest but what it does
allow if you have the wood in here is
allows you to bring the webbing down
into it and finally one of the things
that we enjoyed from the student
exercises was we enjoyed this sort of
homogeneous form that the students had
called it a dog house and we were
invited by the VNA to put an entry in
for an exhibition in London against I
think 16 other architects and they chose
our it was entitled woodshed and we
proposed this very simple form that
would have an afterlife out in the
forest you can't see these images but it
was very important to us how to build it
how to make one joint one material make
a shed this is a mock-up of it and what
was nice about this was this was just me
and the young faculty so that this was
taking that research and moving it
forward without it being having to be a
student thing and this is it built
almost under completion in the VNA burnt
on the exterior very simple same joint
everywhere what else to tell you that's
how the finish of it kind of stolen like
fixed idea from Sigurd levels
and we we end up back at Morissette the
studio is looking at itself right now
and talking about where it gets its
building material but also about how it
lives and how it acts day-to-day so
we've we've started to establish a
kitchen garden we just built ourselves a
kitchen our intent is to turn this into
a farm to feed ourselves better so the
food doesn't travel as far and be more
healthy and that's what we all look like
so I probably blown my time by about
three hundred percent so apology is
Andres I once you you're supposed to say
shut up okay
sorry yeah there's an on/off switch you
know the more you talk the less I have
to oh oh yeah oh you answer already oh
did I ok oh good so we can maybe just a
few questions from my side and then we
will open up to the to the audience
thank you so much this was very very
long very good very intense and I think
we got really a great overview about
what what roast idea was and especially
what it is at the moment and one thing
that comes to my mind is like always
when you're showing me all these project
it's like how do you build in like with
these students coming and going coming
and going how do you build in a memory
how does it's like go on I mean are you
the person like now to keep that memory
I'd like to keep it going or like where
is this sort of memory in it yeah I I
was saved a band before the I think what
one one thing that we do which is a sort
of a luxury we can't we don't have the
finances or the university hasn't got
the finances to hire more professors but
we're able to hire our very best
finishing thesis students so as part of
that conversation about keeping these
projects rolling they they certainly
help they become a an arbitrator between
me and the students they help continue
the energy in a project they they allow
some of that coat that come that
collective memory to reboard back onto
the table but the truth of the matter is
that I'm
I at the moment have to be the glue for
a lot of that and I don't at just it's a
fact of the matter you know if you're
going to do a project in lions park and
it's gone on for six years I was there
six years ago and and they weren't so
holding that together is is my job and
that I really enjoy designing that I
mean I have to say but it it what what's
really super about it is to see
confidence build locally and trust build
locally that that were worth working
with you know and we're able to as a
kind of a neutral arm if your armature
arbitrator we don't have any political
stick would we just want to work with
people are willing to try and do
something and make the place a better
place and so essentially that's what we
try and do and you know we it's a very
emotional situation because you can
never know I mean you know three days
ago the guy who's head of the lies park
committee called me up and he said we've
got a problem Andrew you know and the
problem came directly to me it wasn't
because it was you know we'd had on the
drawing a walking trail for two years
and we just poured the concrete for a
walking trail and suddenly the people
who do work on the rodeo arena said
that's exactly where our horses run out
you know what are you doing our horses
are going to run and fall over your
friggin walking trail and it's that
stuff that is is very it makes it
worthwhile if you can negotiate through
it and and see that the people who also
leading the group buy into it and are
supportive it's not like they panic they
just said well you know this is this has
been on the drawings for two years we've
agreed as a group
you know sorry there's nothing we can do
about this now how are we going to work
out a way forward and such so we not in
some respects that's my job is to be
that liaison between incoming outgoing
students there's the collective memory
of the student body we're not very good
at archiving but I think we're pretty
good at looking at what we've done and
responding to it I mean if you live in
one place and you do this stuff and
you're in a 25 mile radius if you screw
up you got to hear about it and so it's
an amazing kind of fruit has to be an
architect to look at how your work is
aging to be an educator to be able to
point out to the students you know the
beginning of every year I take the
studio on a tour and we talk about what
we did okay and what we screwed up and
why does it look like this and you know
we've got to learn from this something
you can't you're not in a vacuum so I
don't know if I answered any of your
question but absolutely and the other
question is connected with it when we
see like the first image is when you
show us how the the neighborhood looks
like with all this poverty around how do
you choose the projects I mean there's
so much you could do I mean there's so
many people living in trailers and maybe
even not anymore so much but in shacks
and things so there is so much need and
if you start with students like and they
have to find a project it's a little bit
connected with the other question like
who takes a decision like which project
are we retaking this you well the studio
does we we've been there for 18 years
all my staff
live locally locals so I get feedback
that i may or may not want we have been
through a variety of ways of trying to
find clients and appropriate people at
some of various points we've used social
services and then you find out that the
social service folks are sort of
competitively jousting to get their
person as the client and so you don't
get any truth when you go through that
process so what we've done or I've done
is I've started asking people that are
going out there and just people like
mail delivery people people like
furniture delivery people are the guy
that is the head of the local alabama
power who knows whether or not people
are struggling with paying their bills
or if they're genuine is struggling are
they're blowing their money on something
else and then struggling and so it's not
it's not a beautiful situation to play
play God but we have I think enough
feelers out there that we started to
make those choices ourselves and I think
you're never going to get but always
somebody's going to have skeletons in
the closet and you paint so we do a
little bit of that but we're looking for
people that want to be engaged in the
dialogue I think we've moved there's a
discussion in the studio about the
single-family house at the moment
because clearly doing one house a year
isn't helping anybody probably not even
that family but if we can but this week
there's one of those 20k houses has been
built by a local contractor to test in
baby steps the way to take the 20k house
forward can a local guy who thinks he
knows how to building stick frame can he
build ours and how close can he get and
how quickly can you build it and he he
delighted me cuz he came to me first of
all he said you know what I like about
this is that we can bring some money
into the local economy it's like a
cottage industry the local guys build it
you employ local guys if you build 16 of
these a year you bring 327,000 dollar
three hundred twenty thousand dollars
into the economy you're hiring two
people but above the medium income and
this guy's making sixty-five to seventy
thousand that just about makes him a
millionaire locally so come and he said
I love these I said I want these to you
know we can do these because I want my
grandparents living these I want my
family living lease and I want to
imagine how we can make them in a
aggregation and I you know I got
goosebumps when he said this and you
know predictably he's turned out to be a
disaster but it's the first step and I
think we we can I think we can have some
impact with this simply because really
nobody else can afford to do it I mean
y'all could y'all could try one I don't
know how easily you could test one but
we have the ability to design it build
it and be living right next to them
watching how much they're using the
heating and you know how much they're
using the cross ventilation in the
windows and all of that stuff so I I
hope that we can become more relevant
mean I it's nice to make some
interesting little houses that everyone
delights and they bring delight but i
think the twenty-thousand-dollar house
and these these models could really have
some impact not only from living
conditions but from the point of view of
bringing some money to the economy
notice this exactly the reason why
choose this project for the exhibition
because i think it says it like this the
impact is not only like local body can
really reach out in far out like on this
specific condition where you're working
on I think we have not so much time
anymore left so
I would like to open it now question &
Answers family from the audience please
take a microphone when you speak up this
okay let's start here the first question
hello my name is Abdel I guess my
question refers to the transferability
of the knowledge that's learned at the
ruler of studio now I'll give like an
hypothetical situation like someone like
me would go there be a student for five
years from New York and then get the
knowledge there and then come back to
New York and then my question is then
what because it seems like the rural of
part of the rural studio is such a big
part of it so just curious we have any
examples of people doing that or what
you would imagine what happened if it
hasn't happened or something along that
line second question up there um I was
wondering are you talking about some of
the houses are based on like the dogtrot
house did y'all study I guess I need the
local houses or sort of like design
ideas as far as like you say cross
ventilation like how that works designs
and a third question does wyndham I
can't thanks for lecturing I was
wondering if you could give us your
perspective on the employment of unpaid
interns while in school and out of
school especially in terms of there were
both firms that can't afford to pay and
interns that can't afford to work for
free I mean this is perhaps with the
lens of the aaa's perspective on it and
maybe an international perspective jeez
you have the right not to answer the
question all right can I take the fifth
well remind me what yours was if you
come back to New York after working on
so do well I you know as I said at the
beginning I don't think that I'm
suggesting there should be a rural
studio everywhere but I do I hope think
that the students walk away without the
kind of fear that I had when I left
school that they can have a little bit
more control over their future and the
way they decide to lead their lives as
either human beings or as architects I
don't know that we can necessarily be
blamed if there are not that many
opportunities to do similar work I mean
I don't know is it is it a societal
problem there seems to be a desire to do
this kind of work the transferability I
mean I that there are and I don't know
if this is necessarily answering a
question that there are there are
opportunities out there if you've got
the time in the imagination Steve bday
ins for example in Washington does work
on the periphery that nobody else would
do and he he got himself in a position
there where he can negotiate with the
local authorities and contractors and
developers and make things happen in
particularly non-for-profit situations
that that benefits everybody it benefits
the people involved like
you and I but it also meant that
benefits clearly the recipient whether
it's school kids that have a better yard
to play or whatever it is so I think
there are models out there I mean I live
in a I live in an environment and you
know there's there's so much to say
about this situation and it's relevant
to this question as well that you know
that there is no money to police the
building permit process inhale counting
right we work to the southern building
code we look either work to the sudden
building code on the universal building
code right but if we make drawings
there's nobody to present them to and
that's that's that's not our fault but I
think that we take on a moral obligation
to make you know we we don't they not
they don't become like the building code
becomes the design criteria you don't
have something to fall back on if you
decide not to put a handrail in you've
made that choice and so we work very
hard on those choices but so it on
somehow expects it is easy for us to do
this and it is easy to fit more easy to
fit it into an academic situation
because there isn't this sort of well
look we want to look at these drawings
but we we make them and we have
contractors that we have consultants
that work with us that our engineering
all of our projects 200 mile an hour
winds and making sure we hope that none
of that will happen we also have an
architect of record on the projects now
I I don't I sorry i I've spoken too much
than I and I I could go on and on about
getting into this question as to the
unpaid interns I mean I
it it disappoints me that that that
there are and you know maybe it's maybe
you can say that I'm being a hypocrite
but it disappoints me that there are
outstanding architects out there who are
essentially exploiting interns and I
don't think if we don't respect
ourselves who the hell will right that's
that really all I can say about that now
I I hope that what we're doing is
actually showing people that design has
value so I'm not I don't think that I
hope that I'm not exploiting or were not
exploiting our students I think that one
of the interesting things is that
actually we've started to put very real
values on our time and work it in so
that our local folks know what the hell
are getting because you know money talks
right this is what it would cost you in
the real world you all do you understand
this so but but I think there isn't
there's an exchange that takes place
that's so valuable that I don't I don't
want to I don't want to feel like a
hypocrite but because I i feel that
where I hope that we're helping educate
folks to respect design as being a value
right and that might be condescending I
don't know I mean I don't think we do it
over like we are important you know but
I we find we try to scratch design out
of very little and again I'm always
having to look at a project and go well
can this project exists without us
because I I don't want to take food off
the table of the profession I also don't
want to take food off the table of local
contractors so if I can hire a local
contract to do part of it fantastic and
that's what we do
and you know ethically and morally it's
a really it's a fine line it's a
fantastic discussion on the item I don't
know if we should be doing it but as I
say our first question is can this
happen without us and and that's really
the first sort of check on the list as
well the car well then we'll have a
gaudiya but it's hard to you know I know
the local aia were up in arms about the
fire station the fire station just got
an award for the best new or the best
you know public building in alabama for
the last ten years and it was a group
that works with the AIA and it was funny
because I knew that they weren't I was
wondering what was going to happen when
when suddenly for young people get up at
the front and receive the award because
it wasn't it wasn't the resistant it was
an odd moment right and I so I'm very I
I don't want to compete with the
profession I I think if the profession
is interested in what we do and
interested in the discussion about it
and how is it that these folks when
they're 24 years old can make this I'm
interested in talking about that because
some of its pretty good you know so
sorry i did not see personal so I want
to say thank you again thank you so much
for coming and this was really very very
important thanks for listening